c'est c'est monique vous n'êtes pas du
tout dans le coup on était opéra ici
madame mais en état le royal alors
écoutez on est à opéra je connais bien
ce quartier plaisantez ou quoi
nota palais royal ici oui je suis pas
aveugle on est bien au coeur a quand
même si monsieur justement vous êtes un
non voyant
si vous vous êtes trompés mais un très
beau challenge
vous aider à traverser pour vous avez
vous allez droite mme en fait je veux
dire on voudra bercy
attendez vous êtes homosexuel pas du
tout d'être homosexuel nous avons voulu
gérer non mais attendez vous me jurez ce
que je viens traverser mais j'avais
emmené avec moi
allez bonne oui alors amener l'art de la
touche et comment ça peut aller segments
sont prenants michel michel allez bonne
en travers alors je lui propose de lui à
travers son travail
bon bien et échangistes d'échangistes
voilà ce que moi je traverse pour
l'outaouais michel c'est pas possible
e le lou félibre bonne nouvelle est là
mais j'ai rien à ferloo par vous alors
là c'est les verts font la rue par là
vous allez allez c'est vraiment beau
faire plaisir ce que c'est pas du tout
ma direction est là mais je vais opéra
j'y suis c'est bon non palais royal
annonce aucun jeu cassation avant le
changement présentait l'état palais
royal je vous dis pas les vrais musée du
louvre à gauche pas dans l'avion encore
et c'est un chasseur d'épaves a alors
changé une expression
il a la tête à des voitures
grand rodez où je le sache je vois rien
donné des mois alors je sais pas voulu
reconnaître m'embrouiller là je vous
demande est rien ont sauté dessus
tout commence à me faire chier
maintenant je vous aider à traverser
parce qu'on sait jamais venir et s'est
dit prudent avec un aveu passion vous
avez vous aider voilà voilà
faites attention à vos seins mais sa
vraie valeur à une correction de nourrir
à t2 une altitude
abonnez vous en effet un pouce bleus